karen lanza una bola al aire para que la
persiga a su perro la función efe modela
la altura de la bola en metros como
función del tiempo en segundos después
de que karen la lanzó podemos verla aquí
esta es la función f
cuando t es igual a 0 segundos parece
que la altura es de un par de metros y
conforme avanza el tiempo hasta poco
antes de los dos segundos y medio la
bola sube y después comienza a caer para
cuando son casi los cinco segundos la
bola ha caído al suelo su altura es de
cero metros luego nos preguntan cuál de
estos enunciados es correcto elige todas
las respuestas que apliquen pausa en el
vídeo y traten de responderlo por su
cuenta vamos a analizar las opciones la
primera opción dice karen lanzó la bola
desde una altura de 5 metros vamos a ver
si es cierto ella la lanzó desde una
altura de 5 metros si fuera cierto eso
entonces la intersección en ya estaría
en los 5 metros en el tiempo cero pero
claramente esta no es la intersección en
y
dice que ella la lanzó desde una altura
de metro y medio o dos metros yo supongo
que karen no mide cinco metros de altura
y no estaba parada sobre alguna escalera
o algo ella la lanzó desde su altura
normal por lo que descartamos la primera
opción
la segunda opción dice en el punto más
alto la pelota estaba alrededor de 31
metros por arriba del suelo
veamos si es cierto aquí está el punto
más alto y si parece que estos son 31
metros me gusta esta opción por lo que
podemos seleccionarla la bola estuvo en
el aire durante 2.5 segundos aquí vemos
claramente que esto no se cumple la bola
subió durante 2 segundos y medio pero
luego comenzó a ir hacia abajo durante
más o menos otros dos segundos y medio
entonces estuvo en el aire casi cinco
segundos por lo que descartamos esta
opción la bola alcanzó el punto más alto
en el aire más o menos a los 2.5
segundos después de que karen la lanzó
veamos dos y medio segundos después de
que karen lanzó la bola esta se
encuentra justo por acá y parece que
alcanza el punto más alto un poquito
antes de este momento pero como dice más
o menos pues es algo aproximado por lo
que este enunciado es verdadero más o
menos a los 2.5 segundos si hubiera
dicho exactamente a los 2.5 segundos no
la hubiera seleccionado parece que esto
ocurrió a los 2.40 y cinco segundos más
o menos aquí tenemos las opciones que
parecen correctas